- Welcome everyone to tonight's discussion
of the current Dangers
to American Democracy,
sponsored by the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies.
My name's Alan Gerber.
I'm the Sterling Professor
of Political Science
and Director of the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies.
And today, I'm honored to share with you
the insights of our expert
panel on this important topic.
One thing about ISPS,
I just wanna remind everyone,
ISPS is a nonpartisan
research institution.
And you can go to our website
to find out more about
our mission, and our
activities, and upcoming events.
There's gonna be a portion of our events,
which is question and answer.
And so, I wanna encourage
you to send questions
for the panel at any time.
So, starting now through
the Q&A button at the bottom
of your Zoom screen.
And so, we're gonna try and
cover a lot of questions.
So, keep the questions, if you can,
brief and to the point.
And so that'll give us the opportunity
to answer as many questions as possible.
And I just also wanna remind everyone
that today's event is being recorded.
And we hope to be able to
share a link to this event
as soon as possible.
So, now, I wanna introduce
tonight's panelists
in alphabetical order and briefly.
Jacob Hacker is the Stanley Resor,
Professor of Political Science,
co-director of the Ludwig Program
in Public Sector leadership
at the Yale Law School,
and a faculty fellow at ISPS.
He's an expert on American
politics and policy,
a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
and the American Academy of
Political and Social Sciences.
And recently, he created APEX,
the American Political Economy Exchange,
which is a new program at ISPS.
Susan Stokes is the
Tiffany and Margaret Blake,
Distinguished Service Professor
at the University of Chicago.
Sue serves as director of the
Chicago Center on Democracy.
She's a member of the
National Academy of Sciences
and the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
And among her just many
important accomplishments,
Professor Stokes is a
co-founder of Bright Line Watch,
which is a periodic survey of experts
and the public on the state
of American democracy.
And third, we have Milan Svolik.
Milan is a Professor of
Political Science at Yale,
and a faculty fellow at ISPS
who studies the politics
of authoritarian regimes,
democratization, support for democracy,
and democratic backsliding.
His book, the "Politics
of Authoritarian Rule,"
received the Best Book
Award from the comparative
democratization section
of the American Political
Science Association.
So, with that, we now
turn to our panelists
who will speak just one
after another without
additional interruption by me.
So, with that, Jacob, please take it away.
- Great, thanks so much.
So, it's a real pleasure to be here
and to talk about this
somewhat depressing subject.
And there is a reason why
I have up this picture
from a 1980s, don't do drugs commercial.
That was seared into my
memory as I was a child
because I used to wake up early
and watch Saturday morning cartoons.
And so this announcement,
come on, this is your brain.
You've probably seen this one before.
This is your brain.
This is your brain on drugs.
You know, I was watching TV you know,
at 6:00 AM before my parents woke up.
So, then, I was always
wondering when somebody
was gonna actually get me breakfast.
But there's a reason I'm showing this
because in a lot of ways, I
think that what's happened
to our democracy can be well
summed up by thinking about
how it is that a set of polarizing,
and egalitarian changes in
our political economy have
changed the way our
political institutions work,
or as the case may be, don't work.
So, if you think of the ad
for today, it's, you know,
here's your political system,
and this is your political
system on extreme inequality
and hyperpolarization.
You take a context, a system,
and a set of institutions
that was set up in one
era with one set of goals,
and you transport into it a very different
set of circumstances,
and it creates extremely
different outcomes.
And unfortunately, very,
very unsettling outcomes
for many of us.
And so, the way I like to
think about this is that
our political institutions
we're actually very well suited
to helping the United States become
a global economic superpower
in the manufacturing era,
and actually lead the transition towards
a modern knowledge economy.
But those institutions
have proved much less
well-suited to dealing with the strains
and dislocations that have
emerged out of that transition.
And there are two kind
of parts to this story
that I'm just gonna telescope
here and we can talk about.
So, the first part is that these strains,
both the shifts, the social,
and demographic shifts
and the economic shifts that
have occurred over the last
30 years or so, have fueled
a great deal of discontent
and given rise to what Paul Pearson,
and I have called the Backlash
Coalition in our work.
And this coalition is not synonymous with,
but overlaps substantially
with the contemporary Republican party.
And what's important is
it includes not just those
who have been on the kind of front lines
of the economic changes
that have taken place,
those who have faced dislocations,
those who are concerned about
the changing character of the nation,
but it also includes a significant portion
of the American economic elite.
Paul and I called this
plutocratic populism in our work.
And the idea is that
although there's a sort
of common right-wing populous story here,
there's actually a surprising amount of,
if not direct support for
this right-wing populism,
at least and indirect support for it
from some of the biggest
winners in the economy today.
Those who benefited the
most from these changes
that are creating such backlash.
And the other thing that
I wanna emphasize is that
our political institutions
have not proven very capable
of dealing with this
hyperpolarization and inequality.
And there's kind of two
parts to this story.
So, first, just on the backlash coalition,
I think it's really important
to keep in mind that
we don't have to choose between the kind
of common economic story
about how the decline
in manufacturing, the
concentration of prosperity
in cities has led to discontent.
And the equally common,
and I think, also very
persuasive narrative
that this has a lot to
do with concern about
the shifts in America's
racial and ethnic makeup,
and the sense of status
loss that come with it.
I mean, these are both going on
and there's a lot of research
that shows how they come together.
So, for example, the work of David Otto
and his colleagues shows that areas hit
by big manufacturing losses
shift dramatically to the right,
unless they're relatively diverse,
in which case they shift to the left.
But most of the places that have been hit
have been much less diverse.
And the other thing I would say is that
it is pretty important
to keep in mind that
our media ecosystem, and particularly,
the prominent role of right-wing media
that's really important in this
story is pretty distinctive.
And has really accentuated the nature
of this backlash and the intensity
of this backlash coalition.
The other thing to say
is that this backlash,
and this will get me to the institutions
that this backlash coalition
is concentrated in non-metro areas,
which are overrepresented,
as I'll show in our political system.
Now, I just mentioned that
there's also a big role
for politically active wealth,
and I cite a couple studies
here that are very recent
that show that despite the
shifts that we've seen,
there still is a large
amount of support among
the top executive class among corporations
for the Republican party,
even as it become more
right-wing populace.
And so, this poses a
really acute challenge.
And the first thing that
I just wanna mention
is that this challenge is reflected in,
and manifested in the fact that we've seen
the Republican party move
much more dramatically
to the right over the last generation
than we've seen the Democratic
party move to the left.
And you can see this if you
look across countries that,
you know, the Democratic party is kind
of a conventional center left party,
maybe slightly more center than some.
The Republican party is
really far to the extremes.
And I'm sure Sue and Milan
will talk about this,
but the other thing I
wanna mention is that
the sort of political institutions
have accentuated this vulnerability
or accentuated these trends
because they have essentially overweighted
those who are most discontented
with the transformations
in our society and economy
that are taking place.
So, there are two pictures here.
One shows you that you know,
the Senate, as you all know,
has this bias towards
the Republican party.
The Republican party
is essentially not one,
has not represented a majority
of the nation's citizens
in the Senate since the 1990s.
But of course, it is held the Senate
for a lot of this period
and is very favored to
hold the Senate again soon.
And it's very difficult to update policies
to deal with some of the
strains that we're facing
when there is this like very,
this system that is very prone to gridlock
when parties are polarized.
So, there is this kind
of majoritarian threat
that's emerging that we see in particular,
and I think Milan will talk about this
in the degree to which there's
been very aggressive use
of state level election administration
to try to advantage the Republican party.
So, you can see at the state
level in this picture here,
that you know, back in
the 1970s, the Democrats,
if anything, had an edge in gerrymandering
of state legislative districts.
Of course, that's shifted
dramatically in their states
like Wisconsin or Ohio
that are just very heavily skewed in favor
of the Republican party despite being
relatively evenly balanced
in terms of partisan division overall.
And of course,
that feeds into national
political institutions
because of course,
this is where districts get
drawn for national politics.
This is where politicians are drawn from.
So, I don't feel like I could
do this without at least
saying a word about it,
whether there's an opportunity
to escape this vicious cycle.
And in our prior work,
Paul and I have written about
the role of business quite a bit
and argued that if business
which once was a much more
moderate force in our politics
were to do that again,
that that would be really beneficial.
I have to say I don't see that happening
and I'm not sure it
will have as much effect
as we once thought it would,
given how far the Republican
party has moved to the right,
and toward a kind of populist stance.
Ultimately, right, I think,
the right corrective in our
system would be electoral.
And there's a lot of talk
about the fact that Republican
party is kind of exhausting its capacity
to mobilize its voters.
But of course, there's this real challenge
of whether or not the,
there'll be able to be enough
of a response given the
bias of the institutions
to see really corrective efforts
as opposed to further
erosion of democracy.
And so, as I say at the end,
I think that this is an area
where you really need to
see broader mobilization
around electoral and economic reform,
and political reform.
And in that, as, A. Philip
Randolph famously said,
"Organization would be critical."
Thank you.
- Hi, everybody, thank you for coming.
It's great to see you.
And I'm delighted to follow
on Jacob's really
interesting presentation.
I think that there's quite
a bit of overlap between
his insights and mine,
which I'm gratified because
he knows a hell of a lot more
about American politics than I do.
I'm gonna put some of this in a slightly
more comparative framework.
I'm a comparative politics person.
So, basically, you know,
what we've seen in the last
eight years or so in the US
is what we call democratic erosion
or democratic backsliding.
And that, basically,
means that the US like,
about two dozen other countries,
democracies around the world
has experienced a decline
in both horizontal accountability,
which means the ability of
coequal branches of government
to monitor and influence the actions
of the executive branch.
And vertical accountability,
by which we mean the ability
of voters to be well-informed,
and to make use elections
to make decisions
about who their leaders are going to be.
So, despite the fact that in 2020,
Donald Trump was defeated,
American democracy remains fragile.
And that isn't just
because a seemingly more
anti-democratic version
of the former president is poised
to become the GOP's
presidential candidate.
It's also because the
structural causes of erosion
have not disappeared.
And it's had enduring effects
that also continue to,
you know, persist,
and probably make further
erosion that much more likely.
So,
(clears throat) just to put
what's happened in the US
in a somewhat more international context,
the world has experienced
a wave of backsliding
since the late 1990s.
And this figure is a sort
of a illustration of that.
So, the light blue line
is the numbers of coups
happening per year,
and the white line tracks the number
of eroding events each year.
So, and the instigators of the backsliding
come in two basic flavors.
One is right-wing ethno-nationalists,
people like Trump and Victor
Orban of Hungary and elsewhere.
And the other are leftwing populists,
people like Andres Manuel
Lopez Obrador in Mexico
or Jacob Zuma in South Africa.
So, focusing now on
the wealthy democracies
as is the United States, obviously,
why have they experienced
an upsurge in right-wing
ethno-nationalist parties?
Well, you know, with a great
deal of simplification,
I'm depicting the stances
of major political parties
in a lot of, you know,
this sort of describes
I think in general terms
a lot of wealthy democracies,
and how they've kind of array themselves
in the past couple decades.
I'm depicting their stances
on three dimensions.
The vertical dimension is sort
of a traditional large state,
small state, you know,
heavy taxes, light taxes,
one the horizontal dimension,
it has to do with economic
nationalism or globalism.
And then, the sort of the front
to back dimension is about
national identities and the extent
to which those are salient
in the position of political party
and defined in kind of
exclusive or inclusive terms.
In the context
of the later 20th century
de-industrialization,
left parties have shifted
toward more globalist
and somewhat less redistributive stances.
So, that's depicted here as
the sort of the difference
between what I'm calling the
legacy left and the new left.
And in so doing, they
had incentives to do so.
I won't go into why,
but a result of this shift has been
that their brand as parties
of the working class
became somewhat diluted. (clears throat)
The shift in a sense opened up a space
in the southwest and
front corner of this cube
occupied by the ethno-nationalist, right?
So, think of the mega faction
of the Republican party
in the US, Brexiters in the UK,
Sweden Democrats, and many
other parties of this ilk.
Not all of them have gained power
and some of them have gained power,
that's not led to an erosion
of their democracies.
When they get access to power,
why do some of them erode
democracies and not others?
So, a key risk factor,
and this is very much in line
with what Jacob was saying,
a key risk factor that we're finding
in sort of cross national
statistical research
is income inequality.
So, this figure draws
from a cross national
regression analysis
where the dependent variable
is the probability of erosion
and happening beginning in any given year.
And the horizontal axis is genie,
the genie coefficient,
which is a measure of income inequality.
In this case, it's
post-tax, post transfer.
And you know what you're
basically seeing here
is that there is a, you
know, a strong upward trend
as countries become more unequal.
The possibilities of
probabilities of erosion
become stronger.
Obviously, there are a lot
of other factors going on,
and there are other things
that I would mention.
One of them being a kind of contagion
or demonstration effect that we also see.
And I think it helps to account
for the kind of the wave
function that we saw earlier.
But what you see here, you
know, at the highest level
of income inequality countries
like South Africa and Botswana,
the probability of erosion
rises to around 30%.
In countries that are very equal,
so, you know, think the
Scandinavian country, Sweden,
other Northern European countries,
the probability drops to
the low single digits.
Our calculation for the US was about,
in 2017, was about 9%, which
isn't a very big number,
but it's a terrifyingly big
number as an annual probability
of the beginning of an erosion event.
And it's also kind of an
order of magnitude larger
than the calculations of the probability
of democratic instability
when scholars kind of plugged
the US characteristics in that
period into old models that were designed
to explain military coups.
Okay.
- So, I'm sorry.
could you define a
democratic erosion event
just to kind of give folks a sense
of what you're talking about,
some concrete examples of what you mean?
- Yeah, so, actually our measure of this
heavily depends on work by Melis Laebens
who was a graduate student
in her dissertation
that she wrote at Yale a few years ago.
And so, what she stresses is this,
I mentioned at the
outset a kind of decline
in both horizontal and
vertical accountability.
And concretely,
we measured this with data
from varieties of democracy,
which is a Swedish
organization that collects data
on all kinds of things
related to democracy
and other kinds of governments.
So, basically, if you
already are a democracy,
meaning that you've had
a peaceful transition
of power sometime in the last five years,
and you experience a certain
a large enough decline
in measures of horizontal
and vertical accountability,
you get counted as that
would be the beginning
of a kind of a period of erosion.
So, this includes countries,
you know, kind of familiar set
of countries like Hungary under Orban,
as I mentioned, Poland until recent,
then, the polish under
the peace governments,
the US under Trump,
the Mexico under the
current government, Bolivia.
These are now talking more about cases of,
as I mentioned before, sort
of left wing populist erosion.
I'm happy to answer more
questions about that
if that would be helpful.
Okay, so, I alluded earlier
to three wealthy democracies,
all have nurtured right-wing
ethno-nationalist parties.
Only the United States,
by the method that I just described counts
in our calculations and
in most people's books
is a case among these
three of democratic erosion
beginning in 2017.
The UK was kind of a close call.
And it is a country where income
inequality has risen a lot
since the last decades of the 20th century
and approaches the level of the US,
and it was a kind of a close call.
And I can talk more about why.
So, there were elements
of democratic erosion,
but not to the degree that
we saw in the United States.
And then, Sweden is another country
where there's a very powerful,
and very electorally successful right-wing
ethno-nationalist party,
which is now sort of implicitly part
of a governing coalition.
But there's no democratic
erosion in Sweden,
there's no challenge to the
integrity of the judiciary;
there's no questioning of elections
as mechanisms of vertical accountability.
The press doesn't get beaten
up and so on, and so forth.
Okay, so, why does
inequality encourage erosion?
I'm probably running low on time.
Let me just say very
briefly that one reason,
and this is something that Milan
can talk a lot more
about is that countries
that are polarized by income
also tend to have more polarized politics.
And for reasons that
Milan and his colleagues
have explained very well,
polarization tends to
encourage democratic erosion
because voters are more
willing to sort of say,
"Yeah, I don't really like
the fact that this guy
is beating up on the press
or undermining judicial independence,
but God forbid that the
opposition come to power."
So, that's one reason.
And you can see here that
these countries sort of line up
in terms of the level of polarization.
Again, this is coming from VDM data.
A second reason has to do
with what we're calling,
so, the effect of income
inequality on a kind of cynicism
or skepticism about the ability
of political institutions
to make any real difference
in people's lives.
And this is kind of a mood that again,
is kind of encouraged
by backsliding leaders,
and leads to what we're
calling institutional nihilism.
And you can see that we're
finding that in, you know,
sort of measures of
institutional nihilism agreement
to survey questions like,
do you agree that we
cannot fix the problems
in our political institutions?
We need to tear them down and start over.
And when you expose people to,
you remind people about how
unequal their country is,
the US, and we did this in Mexico as well,
you tend to get higher levels of agreement
with those kinds of responses.
So, just to finish up, if you know,
if we wanna have heroes
who are gonna go out
and fight against democratic erosion,
we've got our current
president who's made a priority
of trying to convince people
that democracy is really worth it.
But the other guy here is Sean Fain,
who is the leader of the UAW.
And he and other labor
leaders have have, you know,
led us into a period of some
relative successes in strikes,
and in the ability of unions
to begin to chip away at this,
you know, kind of
extreme income inequality
that our country has experienced,
and that contributes to the erosion
of democratic institutions here.
So, with that, I will close.
- It's an honor to continue
here, and join Sue, and Jacob
in offering my perspective
on how to diagnose
what might be the dangers
to the US democracy.
I would like to do so by
introducing a few elements
of a study that I did
jointly with Matt Graham,
who is our former graduate,
and currently, an assistant
professor at Temple University.
We were trying to figure
out to what extent Americans
are willing to prioritize
democratic principles
over partisan ends.
And crucially, also, to figure
out what do they believe
about others' commitment
to democratic principles,
and whether those beliefs
are warranted in facts.
And here, I'm showing you a slide
that summarizes one
scenario that represented
a representative sample of Americans with,
and we were trying to figure out,
we're trying to find a way to gauge
their commitment to democracy
based on this scenario.
So, the scenario for instance,
summarizes a situation,
a real-world situation
that happened in Missouri.
So, this was a study
that we conducted both in 2020 and 2022.
And this is a scenario from 2020
where the Missouri legislature
was considering changing
how it does redistricting.
And there were two groups advocating
for different ways of doing it.
The status quo was that there's
a nonpartisan demographer,
but there was also another
group called Fair Missouri
that was advocating for
the return of the ability
to direct redistricting
to the state legislature,
which was controlled by Republicans.
So, in effect, partisan
redistricting by Republicans.
So, this is a real-world scenario
and we asked respondents to decide
how they would allocate 10 cents
between these two groups.
What we're interested in
is to what extent people
are willing to allocate
the money to the group
that advocates to more democratic,
the less partisan, what we
call the principled option,
in this scenario that's Clean Missouri,
that advocated for
nonpartisan redistricting.
As opposed to one that may
advance their partisan interests.
In this case, if you're a
Republican, you face a trade-off
between an option that would allow you
to further your partisan interests,
but crucially at the expense of democracy.
And so, let me show you
what happened depending
on whether you were faced with
such a partisan trade-off,
or such a trade-off between partisanship
and democratic principles.
And the first, maybe
illustrate what's going on
is I'll show you what the
Democrats did in this scenario.
In this scenario,
the Democrats, both partisan,
and democratic interests are clear here.
That is they don't want
Republicans to be able
to gerrymander,
and so they should donate
most of their money
to Clean Missouri,
which is advocating for
nonpartisan redistricting.
And that is indeed what happened.
So, next slide here shows
the amount donated on the horizontal axis
to what we call the principled option.
That is the option that
was more consistent
with democratic fair play.
As you can see,
Democrats when faced
between these two choices
in the state of Missouri
were overwhelmingly donating
most of their endowment
to the principled option,
to the group that advocated
for non-partisan redistricting
rather than one done by a partisan,
in this case Republican
controlled legislature.
It reveals, I think two
things, first of all,
the Democrats in this scenario
knew very well where either
democratic principles
or their partisan partisan interests lie.
They donated most of their
money to the principled option.
But now, look what happens
when we asked Republicans
to donate 10 cents, and
how they would donate it,
remember this is the group
that here faces attention
between their partisan interests
and democratic principles.
You see that a majority
of Republicans in fact,
decided to donate less
to the principled option
to Clean Missouri,
and more to the partisan option,
to the group that advocating
returning redistricting powers
to the Republican controlled legislature.
The median donation was
only 3 cents out of 10
to the principled option,
and the mean donation was about 4 cents.
In other words, the average individual
donated a majority of her endowment
to the partisan rather
than the principled option.
And only 29% of subjects
of Republicans in this case
donated to the option
that's more consistent
with democratic principles.
And this in effect highlights
how I view the main
threats to US democracy.
At one level, it is the fact
that this is even possible
that voters in this state get to choose
how redistricting is done.
And I think, in the comparative context,
the United States is
unique in the sense that
state level institutions, legislatures,
sometimes in conjunction with
the governor have the ability,
and as a result the opportunity
to shape the fundamentals
of political competition,
including how redistricting
is done, who can vote,
and so on.
This is very unique around the world,
and it simply creates an
institutional opportunity
to rig the game in one's favor.
The other condition that
I would like to highlight
is in effect the shape of this histogram.
That is that the vast
majority of the type of voter
that in this scenario faced a trade-off
between her partisan interests
and democratic principles
decided to side with partisan interests.
And that is what we find
throughout the study,
both about Democrats and Republicans.
And I see that as the other
main structural condition
that represents a threat to democracy.
And that is that most people
when facing a conflict
between partisanship and
democratic principles
are willing to side with the former.
Thank you.
- Great, thanks very much panelists.
So, the panelists, I guess we
should join as a panel now.
And just, I have a couple quick
questions to kick things off
and then we can turn to
questions from the audience.
So, I wanna just ask Sue,
just a clarification question.
Regarding income inequality,
do you find that the income
inequality relationship
between income inequality
and democratic erosion,
does that hold for high-income countries
as well as low income countries?
So, right. Now, that's the question.
- So, if you interact in,
I let this one answer,
I don't think it's the answer
to the question you're asking,
but we also look at GDP
per capita separately,
you know, as another
factor and find that it-
- Question about interaction,
yeah.
- Right.
I don't remember.
So, my co-author on that paper
is another recent Yale grad named Eli Rau.
Yale is full of amazing
graduate students who...
And I don't remember, I'm gonna find out.
But income itself
has a sort of suggestive
but unstable effect.
You know, the genie effect is just like,
we couldn't get rid of
it no matter what we did,
you know, it was sort of
however you measure it,
however you measure
the dependent variable,
you know, the only way we got rid of it
was like unplugging our computers.
So, it was pretty remarkable.
- Have you tried kicking the computer?
Yeah.
- I do. (laughs)
- Okay, so, and then
my second question,
and this is really for all the panelists,
this is obviously the
idea of democratic erosion
in the United States is a
very frightening prospect.
And at one level, it's obviously,
I'll just say with it's very frightening.
On the other level, you know,
you wonder whether or not
this is a bunch of political scientists
engaging in catastrophizing,
and whether this is a real thing or not.
And so, I mean, each of you or any of you,
could you spell out what
you think of as pathways
that you think are plausible,
maybe, one or two scenarios
that you can think of that would
produce what you've defined
as democratic erosion?
I'm using Sue's term,
but democratic backsliding,
I think that's what Milan
was referring to it as.
And then, you know, just a
little bit about the plausibility
in your view of those scenarios.
Anyone can just start. Yeah.
- Sure, I can jump in real quick.
So, I share that general
orientation that often
I fear that, you know, that
we who are focused so much
on politics can get
ourselves much more upset
than those who are casual observers.
But I think in this case,
if anything I feel like we're
understating some of the risks
and I would say there are two pathways.
So, the first thing to say is,
I think this is very consistent
with what Sue was saying
is that your concern is
erosion, not collapse, right?
The way democracies tend to end,
you know, and a whimper,
not a bang in the contemporary
as Ziblatta and Levitsky
have shown in their book.
And so, what you're really
worried about is this sort
of self-reinforcing process.
And I think both of us are arguing
that inequality polarization,
and the distinctive character
of American institutions,
I would say all three of us are,
but certainly Sue and I
were emphasizing this,
have created a kind of more,
what I call a vicious cycle, right?
Where there is real possibility
of self-reinforcing,
erosion of democratic institutions.
And I don't discount the possibility
that there would be a more
like dramatic single event.
And you know, there's a lot of concern
and I share that concern about
authoritarian minded president
bent on revenge (chuckles)
against political enemies,
and much more savvy about
how to use the institutions
of American government
could well get a lot farther
than said president did while in office.
But I wanted to highlight
that I think the trends
that we've seen that are really
linked to this other form
of democratic erosion too,
namely the sort of creeping
humanitarianism that Milan
talked about in that the
supporting of policies that
and institutional changes
that sort of chip away
at the the hallmarks of democracy.
And that, I think because it
builds on some of the features
of our political institutions
that can be exploited
for partisan gain is in some
ways a kind of more insidious
and difficult to counter form of erosion.
And so, you know, I don't know
if people a generation ago
would've expected the level
of really extreme partisan
gerrymandering that's taken place
and been sanctioned by the court.
Certainly, before the contemporary
urban rural split occurred,
there wasn't nearly as much
of a bias in the institutions
that are now portioned in
favor of less urban places
as we have today.
Or you know, the kinds of challenges
that have taken place at the
state level to election result.
All those seem to be
pretty fundamental shifts.
And then, if we step beyond
kind of institutions,
I mentioned, and I really
wanna emphasize like,
the kind of claims against
democracy that are becoming
and against partisan
opponents that are being used
in extreme media,
particularly on the right,
but on both the right and the left,
I think it's also a
really significant erosion
of core aspects of our
democratic heritage.
So, that, to me, is-
- Thank you.
- Yeah, that's a long
answer to a short question.
But I don't wanna say we
should all be freaked out.
It's not like in that scene in a airplane,
if you remember that '80s funny movie
where like there's a sign
that said don't panic
when the plane started going down,
and then, at one point,
it just shift to panic
and everyone jumped up
and started screaming.
I'm not saying panic,
but I'm saying be concerned
and be focused on what
are the real sources
of this erosion.
- Good, Good. Thank you, Jacob.
Sue, what what are some
of the scenarios that
in the US context you
think of as worrisome?
And then, Milan is now back.
- So, one of the things that I
worry about in the US context
is the unshakeability of
Donald Trump's electoral base.
And it's sort of seeming
kind of insularity
from any kind of, you
know, negative information
or negative facts about the candidate,
about the party, about the policies.
When you look at other countries
that have had periods
of erosion and kind of,
and kind of set them aside,
one of the things that you see is that,
you know, parties lose elections,
and eroding parties lose elections,
and they really kind of,
it's possible to undo
some of what happened,
you know, and you don't have the same,
sometimes you have
challenging of the election.
So, Jair Bolsonaro in Brazil
was very much like Trump
in that he claimed before the election
that there was gonna be massive fraud,
but he didn't really
double-down on that claim
afterwards so much and that's probably
because he was really
worried about prosecution,
and he is being prosecuted.
So, but you know, the UK is
an interesting experience
because they really did
have a very close call,
maybe closer call than
we realized in the US.
So, the proration crisis
where Prime Minister Johnson
closed down the parliament,
which is not something that never happens,
but it was found that he had
done that in a unlawful manner.
I'm not sure what
unlawful and illegal are,
the difference between them,
but that's what the
court decided in the UK.
And so, that's kind of a big thing.
And then, they also have
engaged in you know,
restrictions to ballot access.
You know, like the US a country
in which there's very
little electoral fraud.
In fact, the elections are much more
heavily regulated there.
And the right to protest
has been curtailed in ways
that have been lasting.
In fact, we saw a lot of drama around that
the last few days.
But what happened to Johnson
was that he was dumped
by his political party.
And he was dumped by his political party.
And granted it's a, you
know, parliamentary system,
it's easier for the party to
get rid of his prime minister.
You don't need a new election,
you don't even need a
party election there.
But the reason he was dumped
was that he was very unpopular
or to put it the other way around,
had he had the persistent
kind of level of popularity
that Donald Trump has in the US,
they might well have hung onto him,
and then we might have seen
more of an unraveling in the UK.
So, that's a real source
of concern for me.
- Great, thank you.
Milan, do you have
anything you wanted to add?
- I apologize, I just
appeared for a minute there.
And was it the question
about what are the?
- Yeah, the question is
are there any scenarios
that you might, that
you know, that just...
Basically, are there any scenarios
that you are especially worried about?
You've mentioned state level
machinations in your presentation.
Is that what you're
concerned about mostly?
Or what are the things you're
concerned about in terms
of scenarios for democratic backsliding?
- So, those state level, you know,
disenfranchisement, gerrymandering
that was happening before
the Trump presidency,
it's happening now.
And those are the
institutional opportunities
that are unique to the United States
and that are being taken
advantage of by both parties.
And I think that's very concerning.
And maybe, let me add two other elements
that I think are structurally different,
let's say, from what was
happening four years ago
or six years ago.
And the first one is,
I think, that similar
to what Sue mentioned,
that post-January 6th
republicans are different.
And maybe, one way I would
describe this in concrete terms
that we see it in the study
that I briefly previewed.
As I mentioned, we conducted
two studies, one in 2020,
just before the 2020 election,
and another one in the 2022 election.
And what we saw in the
study conducted just prior
to the midterms that is
after January 6th, 2021,
is that we saw that republicans
are unwilling to punish.
So, whereas in 2020 they were,
but in 2022, they were unwilling to punish
one type of undemocratic behavior,
and that is denying the
outcome of elections,
questioning the fairness or
the conduct of elections.
When their candidate was claiming,
and these were real world
candidates that were,
simply questioning the results
of the 2020 presidential
elections or some other elections,
Republican voters were
willing to go along with it
in some cases that carried a premium.
And so, that's very different
from the kind of partisan asymmetry
that we have observed before.
But actually, voters on
both sides were willing
to overlook democratic
defects on their own side.
This is very different now.
And maybe, the last comment
I would have is that
another feature that is different
from just a few years ago
is that both sides are
increasingly willing
to justify their own undemocratic behavior
by pointing to the other
sides on democratic behavior.
So, to maybe, give one concrete example,
the Democrats when they
redistricted the state of New York
just before the 2022 midterms,
that redistricting was ruled
as unconstitutional in New York
because it was gerrymandered.
But the rationale that was given is that
we have to do this because Republicans
are doing this elsewhere.
And if we don't do this,
we'll be hurting ourselves politically.
And if you look at some
of the commentary on this,
and reporting what was interesting,
that is the journalist
sometimes noted and you know,
and no voter is going to punish
their own party for gerrymandering.
So, there's no political cost to this.
And I think this kind of tit for tat
where one side is saying
we have to play dirty
because the other side
is already doing it,
can kind of spiral out of control.
- Okay, well, that is a really
a great way to transition
to the questions
'cause I find that really
(chuckles) disturbing,
I mean, the idea that sort
of norm violation leads
to a kind of spiral of escalation,
you know, of norm violation.
That is, I would just say,
I'm sorry, maybe I should stop here.
But I would say the scenarios
that seem most disturbing
to me for extreme problems
have that feature to them
where people start down
on a set of things,
they start down a path,
which through a series of,
I have to do this because they did this,
or if I don't do it, they'll do it.
That logic can lead you
very far down the road
in a scary direction.
And anyway, on that note,
why don't we turn to our audience.
Rick Harrison has synthesized
some of the questions.
And so, I'm gonna read
some of them to you.
And let me just go ahead.
And anyone who wants, I
don't think any of these,
at least the first bunch are not directed
to any particular panelists.
So, whoever thinks they
have something insightful
to say should please share
that with our audience.
Okay, here's a question.
Peter Turchin has written that,
"We are in for a period
of ongoing instability
because of four underlying
societal forces,
popular commiseration
leading to mass mobilization,
potential, elite overproduction,"
which that's his famous hypothesis about
elite overproduction,
"failing fiscal health and
weakened legitimacy of the state
and geopolitical factors.
And so, some of those
things were mentioned by,
I guess, Jacob mentioned at and as well,
Susan, and also, I guess, Milan as well.
What do you think about the
implications of this thesis?
What do you feel about the thesis?
Do you find this a useful,
this a lead over product,
especially a lead over production
and legitimacy problems?
Do you find that a useful framework?
And how does that help you
think about these questions?
I'm very interested in
hearing what you think about
a lead over production.
But anything in this question
I'd be interested in
hearing your reaction to.
Are you familiar with this
elite over production thesis?
Okay, we don't have
enough time to go into it.
But basically, if I've got it right,
when you produce more political elites
than you have places for them in society,
that's the tinder for political conflict
and potential major changes
in the political system.
And this, I think, goes
back to, is it Pareto?
Who talked about elite
fractures being the foundation
for a political change as opposed
to mass based political change.
Obviously, you know,
what a great comparative
politics scholar I am.
So, any (chuckles) comments
from our colleagues on that?
I'm tempted to say we're
gonna edit this part out
of the video.
Okay, next question.
So, any comments please? Yeah.
- I don't know if I have anything
to say on elite over production,
but I will say that the
role I think both Sue
and I were emphasizing the
degree to which the concentration
of economic rewards is
quite consequential.
That's one kind of elite.
Actually, I think, probably
one of the big problems
in our politics today is this
linked to what you were saying
about norm erosion is the
people who go into office
increasingly have to be
partisan warriors, right?
And so, you know,
I think we really can't understate
the role of elites in this process.
So, in both shaping how
non-elites are thinking,
but also, in turn their own struggles.
And so, one thing that
I think is quite clear
is that the pool of people
who are going into public office now
is very much shaped by both this very
bifurcated media ecosystem
that I alluded to.
And by the sense,
that there's a struggle
that's existential struggle
that each party is engaged in.
And I do think there are differences
between the parties in this regard.
And I've been studying the
Democratic party a lot lately
'cause I was studying the Republican party
for so much in my career.
And I do think one thing that is different
is that the Democratic party
still has a lot of people who,
for one of a better way of putting it,
kind of wanna do policy.
And that has a kind of cohesive,
it induces a kind of
cohesion across the party.
If you look at the
Republicans say in the house,
one of their big problems, right?
Is that they lack this kind
of common denominator of,
well, we just wanna like do policy things
through government, right?
There's sort of one faction
that's trying to win favor on
conservative social media.
There's other factions that
would like to do policy things.
There's others that would think
the Supreme Court's
really all that matters.
You know, and so, I
think creates a much more
fractured party
and I think fractures kind of bad.
Like, I think that in
general you want parties
that can behave a bit more cohesively
and will discipline of
course their members
when they're behaving in ways
that sort of reflect poorly
on the party overall.
And so, not to to paint
the Democrats as being
really high performers in this regard.
But I do think one thing that
we should be thinking about
is like what, you know, how
does a Republican party,
because our system does not
work without two parties
that are relatively well functioning.
How do we get the
Republican party to function
as a more cohesive party,
and not just in the way
that Milan suggest they
might function as a party.
So, I'm sorry that I was
exactly on elite overproduction,
but I actually think it's really important
to think about the elites
in American politics,
and how they play into this process.
- Okay, Sue, Milan,
do you have anything you wanna say?
Or like, we should move
on to the next question?
- Sure, next question sounds great.
- Okay, next question.
Do you think that the
candidate selection mechanism?
So, we've got the situation
in the United States
where we have Donald Trump
and Joe Biden likely to be the
next presidential candidates.
That's a function to a great extent
of the political institutions
for selecting office holders.
Is there anything in your
research that suggests
that they're better and worse ways
in terms of the political institutions
that might help us to
avoid democratic erosion?
So, just to amplify on this a little bit,
you suggested these deep
structural economic factors,
attitudinal factors.
Are there any institutional
factors that might be helpful?
I mean, Milan of course,
discussed the state level
institutional authority.
But sue any of your
comparative politics work
that might give us ideas about better
and worse political institutions?
Or Milan, anything that you would suggest?
- So, you know, I think that there are,
it's commonly viewed that
there are aspects of the way
that we select candidates and
elect office holders in the US
that contribute to polarization,
and to party, and discipline
that Jacob was just discussing.
And there are some kind of
structural aspects of that.
So, the United States has gone through
sometimes called the great sort
where we have an increasing
kind of homogenization regionally,
and I electoral district of
in, so, less heterogeneity
in terms of political
preferences and other factors.
So, that tends to produce representatives
who are not vulnerable to losing elections
or to the other party,
but rather that the dynamic
tends to be within their own party.
And that that can contribute
to the kind of polarization
that Milan was talking about.
There actually has been,
I mean, there are trade-offs involved
in all of these kinds of
institutional factors.
So, in Latin America where I
have more regional expertise,
there actually has been a
shift toward party primaries,
not so much for metaverse of legislature
who tend to be elected in
proportional representation
on party lists,
but for executives, for presidents.
And the reason parties
like to do that is that
it opens the process and
potentially chooses more popular
candidates who will do better
in the general election.
And also, I think, gives
voters a sense of ownership
having participated in an open primary,
and decided, well, I'm
gonna vote it in the PAN
primary in Mexico, I'm
more likely then to go on
and vote for the pun
candidate in the election.
So, there are trade-offs.
But there certainly are
some particular features
of American institutions,
which Jacob was talking about
as well as Milan, that tend
to increase polarization.
I'm just gonna add one other thing.
This is kind of adding to the mix,
the super interesting
conversation about polarization.
So, one of the drawbacks of
polarization as a strategy
of democratic odors is that
it mobilizes your base,
but it also mobilizes the other guys.
So, you know, Donald
Trump says the Democrats
are an angry mob who
want to open the border,
and so on, and so forth.
And you know, that gets
his folks revved up,
and it also tends to
get Democrats revved up.
So, there's a another strategy
that we have been
detecting in our research,
another kind of rhetorical strategy that
we call trash talking democracy.
Milan has heard about this (chuckles)
where it's not so much you
don't badmouth the other party,
you badmouth the institutions.
So, you know, the courts
are full of corrupt actors,
the press is incompetent.
You know, the opposition and
the legislature are, you know,
the legislature is, you know, unworkable.
And so, the impact of that is to,
we find just as an empirical matter
to kind of tamp down any kind
of enthusiasm or optimism
about institutions working.
And that's also something
that I think is very,
is sort of exaggerated
in the American context
because we do this,
this goes back to what Jacob was saying,
we do have a whole, you know,
big chunk of one of our
major political parties
who are people who really
don't believe in government,
and don't believe in public policy,
and sort of make the failure
to provide good services,
a kind of self-fulfilling function.
There's a wonderful book
by an American sociologist
Arlie Russell Hochschild about
why is it the people in
cancer alley in Louisiana
who understand perfectly well
that they're being poisoned
by the petrochemical industry.
Why did they support
Tea Party anti-environmentalist lawmakers?
And one of the reasons is that they see
that even at the state
level that, you know,
the kind of EPA equivalent
in the state of Louisiana
does a terrible job.
They don't get anything done.
They don't actually protect them.
Of course, that's a result of defunding,
and you know, a kind of
starving of the institution.
But then that becomes evidence that
there's no point in electing,
you know, environmentalists.
Representatives are
trying to push agencies
to do a better job because
you have before you,
you know, evidence that these
institutions don't work.
- Thanks, Sue.
Milan, do you have any comments?
- Maybe just some comments on
this institutional question.
So, I don't see much of a, you know,
I don't see clear evidence
favoring or not favoring a system
with party primaries over a
system without party primaries.
But what strikes me as
being directly relevant
to democratic erosion is the fact that
the very tight two-party
system that exists
in the United States
creates a very stark
choice for voters, right?
So, if one party's proposing a candidate
that has authoritarian tendencies,
but at the same time, represents
in a meaningful sense,
also the policy preferences of voters,
then a supporter of
those policy preferences
faces a tough choice.
They might vote for a
candidate who is democratic,
but on the other side,
politically as in advocating
for policies that they disagree with,
or they must put up with a
candidate who is, you know,
violating democratic norms,
but also, happens to advocate
for the kind of policies
that they like.
And this is a very stark binary choice
that's in effect a product
of the two-party system.
And that in most places,
which have multiple parties
does not have to be as stark
because in addition, let's say,
to a conservative who is authoritarian,
there will be also a party that also
has conservative leanings
but is perfectly compliant
with democratic principles.
And so, in some sense,
democracy has a very high price
in the United States
for a subset of voters
who face these kind of trade-offs.
And so, in terms of
institutional solutions,
I'm kind of very much interested in
what's going to come
out of the ranked choice
voting experiments,
(Alan speaks faintly)
which still in the US
function in the context
of the two major parties.
But because they do not have
a stark diversion pressures,
they do not face voters
who may have somewhat
eclectic combination of preferences.
They may not be aligned exactly
the way the two major parties are.
They may be sincerely voting
for their first preference
without having to sacrifice their vote.
- Great, thank you.
I mean, I guess, another issue related
to what you were saying, Milan,
is that when you have two parties,
if you trash the other party,
it's a sum zero game.
Whereas if there are multiple parties,
trashing the other party
may or may not read down
to your benefit to the same extent.
- I think that would be
the interaction effect
between Sue's comments and my comments.
- Excellent, thank you. Wonderful.
Next question, to what extent, if any,
might the effects of disinformation,
apart from the effects
of objective conditions
such as inequality affect your analysis?
So, I guess, the general question
is to what extent is
the erosion of democracy
affected by the information
environment that,
you know, we're now experiencing?
- I mean, I should say I've
mentioned right-wing media,
and media in general a number of times.
So, I'll just emphasize
that again and say that,
one way that inequality has factored in,
or at least this is what
Paul and I argued in our book
"Let them Eat Tweets,"
is that that inequality
by creating essentially tensions
for both parties coalitions,
but particularly, for
the Republican coalition
with its longstanding ties to business,
but it's increasing reliance
on working class white votes.
For that party to try to shift
the focus of conflict from
kind of first dimension
material size of government
issues towards more
what sometimes called
second dimensions issues
around race cultural conflict.
And I just wanna be clear,
if there's a lot of
second dimension appeals
made by Democrats as well,
but I think it's really
important to see how
that strategy, right?
Has been both.
So, that's not a direct effect
of inequality, if you will.
It's an effective inequality
that's mediated by political strategies,
competition between the parties.
John Roemer, our colleague, now retired,
made a argument along
these lines many years ago,
which is basically if you introduce
these second dimensions of conflict,
then you're gonna get
these cross class parties.
They're gonna be cleaved much more
around cultural and social issues.
And with the Republican
party in particular,
there's just no question
that that strategy, right?
Which took the objective change,
but then translated into
a certain kind of response
has been greatly furthered by the rise
of a distinctive
right-wing media ecosystem.
And so, it starts as Talk radio,
it runs up into and through Fox News,
which now is a moderate player
in some of the right-wing media circles.
There has been a ton of
research on this that shows
that there is a lot of disinformation
and misinformation in this
more isolated ecosystem.
Perhaps the most persuasive argument
that I've seen about this,
because of course,
these can become like
essentialist arguments,
like, somehow, the right wing is gonna be,
is more prone to dishonesty.
But actually, the best argument I've seen
is just the nature of the
ecosystems themselves.
So, the left of center
ecosystem is kind of broad one
that includes a lot of
mainstream media, right?
It's just much more likely to police
very inaccurate and extreme stuff, right?
Right-wing media system is
a more self-contained unit.
That's true both in terms
of how these media nodes
kind of interact with each other
as Yochai Benkler has shown in his work.
But it's also true in
who actually consumes the media, right?
So, if you're someone
who dabbles a little bit
in this range of media,
which is true of a lot of
people in the center, right?
Then, you're gonna get
exposed to a bunch of stuff.
If you look at the people,
particularly the most strong
supporters of kind of,
we've sometimes talked to 'em
about them today as you know,
MAGA, Make America
Great Again, candidates,
those folks are much
more likely to congregate
among the most conservative media sources
where they're not
necessarily getting exposed
to some of that contrary information.
So, again, I just think
it's really important
that we understand that our
institutions are distinctive.
And also, if you look across countries,
there are very few countries,
I think Israel is really the major example
that you see in the
cross national research
where there's so much distrust,
particularly among conservatives
of mainstream media sources,
and where there's so
much reliance on a kind
of distinctive brand of
media of bipartisans.
- Great. Milan, and Sue.
Do you have anything to add about
the communication environment?
I can't tell if Milan,
are you looking to get rid of your mute?
Or are you?
- I apologize. No, I don't
think I have anything to say.
- Okay. Sue, do you have
anything you wanna add?
- No, I agree with.
- Terrific. Okay, question.
Thank you all for your informative talks.
Okay, I agree with that.
Go. Okay.
What are some actions that can be done
or are already being done to counteract
the erosion of democracy?
Sue.
Actually, Sue, could you
also say just a word about
what Bright Line Watch is?
'Cause, I think people who
are interested in this topic
might be interested in learning
more about that as well
as your answer.
- Yeah, for sure.
- 'Cause, I think, it's
relevant to the question of,
you know, what can you do
about the erosion of democracy?
Is a public that's more alert
to the the fact that there are threats
to our democracy is
probably part of the answer
to that question.
- So, there, you know,
I think participation is super important.
So, thinking about what we can
do as individuals who may be,
you know, students, or professors,
or people you know, working in, you know,
non-official kinds of jobs.
Participation is very
important if, you know,
Milan is completely right, that
we have all kinds of biases
and tendencies to turn a blind eye
to undemocratic behaviors
by our own parties.
But to the extent that it
becomes really crucial,
and I think we are really at a crossroads
in our country right now
to sort of, you know,
recommit to democracy as a
kind of system of government,
and set of principles,
and make that a kind of central point
to your own participation,
and the way you talk to
other people about politics,
separate from the kinds
of public policy issues
that we all care a lot about.
Many of us care very passionately about
public policy issues.
But separate from those kinds of concerns,
I think that there is a real
need to sort of think hard
and talk hard, you know,
talk with people about
what is it that democracy does,
and what does it look like
it doesn't do very well.
And you know, I talked a moment ago about
this kind of phenomenon of
eroding backsliding leaders
having a strategy of
denigrating democracy.
Not so much democracy writ large,
they usually say it's a
good system of government,
but these particular
institutions really are hollow,
and corrupt, and not worth it.
So, don't worry about
it when I attack them.
So, you know, I think
there's a dialogue to have
with many different kinds of people.
I personally feel a strong
need to have a dialogue
with the left on this
and with young people.
And I started my own household
where I have, you know,
teenagers who are skeptical for sure,
and who are quick to pick up
on the failures of democracy,
even when it works pretty well.
So, we have all kinds of, you know,
so, the way to defend democracy
is not to whitewash it,
is not to say it has worked very well
in the history of the United States.
It has had all kinds of biases,
and has institutionalized
many elements of racism,
and sexism, and all kinds of things
that we want to overcome.
Nevertheless, if you study the experiences
of other countries where
people lose the ability
to kick the government out
of office by voting them out,
that is not a good place to be.
It's a place to be where civil
rights are not respected,
where the rights to
protest are not respected,
where freedom of speech is not respected.
So, I think that a kind of thinking hard
about the difference
between a sharp critical
constructive eye toward our
own political institutions,
as opposed to, you know,
the kind of institutional nihilism
that many political
leaders are only too happy
to encourage us to embrace.
That's an important starting point.
- And could you just say a
quick word about project.
- (speaks faintly) Much, yeah.
So, in late '20, when was it?
I guess, it was coming up
to the election in 2016.
A lot of economists got very upset
because candidate Trump
was raising questions
about the veracity and reliability
of official government
statistics on things
like unemployment rate.
And they wrote a public letter
that was signed by many former, you know,
Nobel laureates and former presidents
of the American Economics
Association so forth,
that said,
"Hey, you know, where would we be without
the Bureau of Labor statistics?
Where would we be without
these institutions?"
It's not a good thing to question
these very important institutions,
and question sort of the
scientific basis of economics.
And I remember I was having a conversation
with our colleague,
Gresham Helmke at the
University of Rochester
and sort of very smugly saying,
"Oh, these economists,
they sure wait till the
last minute to do this."
And then, it was then, she sort of said,
"Hey, have we done anything like this?"
So, we circulated a letter
of great concern about,
you know, the threat that you know,
certain parts of the discourse,
and sort of, you know,
attacks on the press
that point verbal attacks
on the press attacks on,
you know, very virulent
attacks on political opponents,
on immigrants, and so forth,
that seemed to represent
a potential threat to
democratic institutions
in the United States.
And that elicited a very,
very strong response.
We had, I think, every, almost
every living past president
of the American Political
Science Association
and just scores of our
colleagues signed the letter.
And after the election,
we thought, okay, we should do something.
And the first thing we decided to do
was to put together an
email list of our colleagues
around the country,
and get them to tell us what they think
matters for democracy.
So, we have, as those
of you who filled out
these long surveys,
now, they're in about
27 different dimensions
that we talk about what is democracy?
And then, that same set of dimensions,
you know, how are we doing?
How's the US doing on these things?
And we've branched out and
done other kinds of questions,
and other kinds of studies.
But that's the basic.
So, it's a collaboration between
Dartmouth University of Rochester,
and was Yale, now University of Chicago.
- Great. Thank you very much, Sue.
Again, the question, what are
some actions that can be done
or are already being done
to counteract the erosion of democracy?
Milan, is there something
you'd like to add to that?
- Maybe, briefly to
characterize what I think
is the main force that is, you know,
that acts in, you know,
to defend democracy.
And I think that main
force are the voters.
I think as voters as
being the ultimate check
on any possible politician
that undermines democracy.
And I think when we think
about what kind of voters,
the kind of study that
I highlighted earlier,
I've tried to do several
of those around the world
and basically, try to
look at what are the kind
of characteristic of the kind of voter
that when the kind of party or candidate
that they would normally vote for
says something undemocratic
or proposes something undemocratic,
that that voter is willing to say,
"I'm not voting for you just
because of that." Right?
And I think,
there are two actionable
predictors of that kind of voter
or correlates of that kind of voter.
And the first type is,
well, that kind of voter tends
to be a centrist or moderate, right?
So, they are not hard line partisans
because those are unwilling
to abandon the candidates
that they otherwise like.
So, in other words, centrist
are a pro-democratic force.
But the other thing that's even,
that I think is more actionable
is that these voters tend
to be fairly political informed
and democratically competent.
They seem to be fairly
good at telling apart
undemocratic from democratic,
but also knowing basic political facts.
And I think, so, I think, if there's hope,
it's the hope in this kind of
voter as serving as a check.
- Right, so, it it's not causal exactly,
it's an association, but it makes sense.
- It's an association and
it's one only of about four
or five robust predictors
across about 10 countries.
And so, I think that that's
the kind of surprising thing
is like, regardless of
whether we're talking about
Serbia, Sweden, or the United States,
this is something that strongly
correlates with the kind
of voter who's willing to say,
"If it's my side that's
behaving undemocratically,
I'm willing to switch
and vote for someone else
precisely because they're
behaving undemocratically."
- Milan, is this work
part of the APSR paper
that you publish with matter?
Or is it some other?
- This is not published.
This is not published.
- Okay.
All right, so, this is breaking news.
- But it's based on
those studies, basically.
Looking now at the correlates
of the kind of voter
that sides with democracy.
- Okay, but for people who
are interested in reading more
about what you've been talking about,
the study that you showed excerpts from,
that's an American Political
Science Review paper
with Matt Graham from 2022.
So, there is a paper there,
although, this one, which I
showed is also a working paper.
- This one?
- Yeah.
This one is more focusing
on partisan mistrust.
- Great, thank you.
Jacob, is there something
you'd like to add?
- Yeah, just, I'd just like to say first,
Bright Line Watch is a great organization.
I'm so pleased that it's out there,
and I, at least, think
it has a presence at Yale
because there's a lot of us
who admire it and draw in it.
And I think that if I could
bring these comments together,
I'd say two things.
One is, yes, voters are kind
of the ultimate corrective
and democratic system, but
the voters need help, right?
Both, they need institutions
that allow them to have
an effective voice,
and they need the kind of information
and support to be able to exercise that.
And so, there I come
back to this idea that
there's a real need for
building up organizations,
broad, kind of civic
organizations of the sort that,
you know, used.
I think labor unions played
a very important role
in this regard, as Sue said.
But we also have,
as Theta Scotch Bulls
work has suggested, right?
We had a large number
of kind of mass based civic organizations,
some of them fraternal organizations,
some of them veterans groups
that were much more active
in sort of mobilizing citizens,
and reforming them around broad issues.
And I would say that,
I am short-term very
worried as I've made clear,
but I have a kind of long-term optimism
and it rests on a couple things.
One is that, you know, as we've discussed,
there's a bunch of ideas
out there for reform, right?
It's really what's the
challenge right now?
It's like the political,
it's like lifting yourself up
by your own bootstraps, right?
The political system
isn't working very well.
How do we fix the political
system in those circumstances?
But we kind of know the formula
and I'm really pleased that you, Alan,
had created democracy innovations,
which is thinking through
some of these really innovative ideas
for how to improve the performance of.
No, actually, I think,
how do we get through this period
where we can't actually
pursue those ideas?
We can experiment, we can think
about state level changes.
But I also think, as Milan
was suggesting, right?
We can get engaged and
if there's one thing
that I think Bright Line Watch
does that organizations do,
that Milan's stronger democrats
in the electorate do, right?
Is they try to focus attention on
what the stakes are, right?
That's a little bit of what we're doing,
but at least, I don't have illusions about
how many people are listening.
Well, I can see right
now, 108 of you out there.
Thank you for listening.
So, and hopefully, you have
lots of friends you can talk to,
but I think one of the
things that's happened
is we've kind of normalized
pretty fundamentally
anti-democratic stances.
And we need to essentially say that
these are not appropriate.
And that's gotta be part of our debates.
I actually think it's striking that
in the last two big elections.
Actually, probably if you
go back to 2018 too, right?
There's been a lot of hand wringing,
and in the end where there's
been salience of the state
about the stakes, right?
Where there's candidates
who are really out there
denying elections where, you
know, very fundamental rights
that people care about are at stake.
We've generally, not exclusively,
we've seen greater engagement, right?
And we've seen a lot of
positive breakthroughs
for shoring up those institutions, right?
And so, I think that's the hope, right?
Is that you get that going,
that kind of positive cycle
rather than the vicious cycle going.
And I believe over the long term we can.
- Excellent. Thank you so much, Jacob.
And so, I see that we're at 5:23.
I do wanna say thank you
for the call out Jacob
to the ISPS Democratic
Innovations Program.
We have a lot of events that
are planned in the coming
several months, including
a fairly large event,
a conference event on rank choice voting,
and we're having an event
on the use of lotteries and
representational systems.
And all sorts of things designed to try
and think of systems that
would promote honest,
efficient, and effective government.
And I urge everyone who's
interested in such things
to check out the ISPS
website for more information.
So, with that, why don't
we see are there any final,
like, literally, 30 to 45 second comments
that you'd like panelists to make.
And if there's any resources or papers
or books that you think
would be especially important
for people to read who are
interested in the subject,
could you share those as well?
We're kind of getting close to
the end of our time together.
So, why don't we start in reverse order
from the presentation.
So, Milan, Sue, and then Jacob, please.
- Maybe very briefly,
I would say that what
I want to keep up with,
what political scientists and
what the public think about
the state of the US democracy.
I keep up with the website
of the Bright Line Watch
and especially, their reports on,
I'm really fascinated by both
how much actually agreement
there is between political scientists
and ordinary voters about many things,
but also, then the lines of disagreement.
So, I find those periodic
studies incredibly valuable,
and kind of, especially if
they're around major events
in American politics, like,
I see it as a social scientific
way to better understand
the challenges to democracy.
So, I really appreciate that.
- Thank you, Sue.
- Thank you. Thanks, Milan.
One thing I would add is that
we actually have replicated
the same set of questions
about dimensions of democracy,
you know, what's important
in, I don't know,
six or seven different
countries, very varied,
Brazil, Poland, the UK, South Africa,
bunch of different countries.
And it's startling how
similar the results are.
So, the view, you know,
what really matters for democracy?
What's essential?
You know, people think
that equality of rights,
of political rights, they
think that elect, you know,
free and fair elections far and away
the most important thing.
And also, what doesn't matter so much.
So, they actually, the votes
pope is that getting along
and being nice to each
other isn't so important.
I think, you know, like having legislators
who, you know, go out to
dinner together to whatever,
not that they don't think it's important,
it's not as important.
So, there's a lot of
conversions of the ideas about
what democracy is internationally,
I guess, I would just say
for folks who are interested
in thinking about what you can do
and less of our kind of
nerdy papers that we write.
Another Yale professor,
Tim Snyder in the history
department, his book on his,
sort of really basically
pamphlet "On Tyranny"
has a wonderful set of ideas about
very concrete things you can do,
like get subscriptions to newspapers
and choose an organization
that you wanna champion,
and help labor unions, and so on.
So, I would take a look at Tim's book.
- Great, thanks a lot, Sue.
And then, Jacob, please.
- Yeah, so first, if you didn't notice,
'cause Sue was talking,
I was holding up "On Tyranny,"
which is right next to my desk.
But I was also gonna mention
I'm part of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences Commission on
"Reimagining the Economy."
And it's a successor to the,
this is an embargoed copy,
and the real thing
doesn't have the binder,
but it's a successor
to a well-known report
that they did on improving the
Health of American democracy.
And I think, it is telling
that, first of all,
you could get together a
very broad cross section
of people from very wide range of fields.
And they all agreed that our future
and our democracy
depends on thinking about
how our we can make our economy
work better for more Americans.
And that kind of brings us full circle
to where both Sue and I began
that, you know, ultimately,
like capitalist democracy has this,
you know, among rich democracies
has this pretty impressive
track record of resilience
in the face of a lot of
very fundamental shocks.
And it rests on this idea that,
as Milan said, that voters have autonomy.
It also rests on the prosperity
that wealth well-regulated
markets can produce.
And it's that, you know,
that complementarity
as political scientists call
it, of capitalism, democracy,
that with reforms to both
capitalism and democracy
should get us forward into the future.
- Great.
- And so that,
I think it's really great that,
and yes, I know,
I think it's really great the
academy has put out a report
for how we might think about that.
- Fantastic. Thank you so much, Jacob.
So, I wanna also thank our staff at ISPS.
We have the most amazing
staff that allow us
to do these events, especially
Pam Green, Rick Harrison,
and Kira Wishard who did
all of the arrangements
to make this event possible.
I wanna thank our panelists,
Sue Stokes from Chicago,
Milan, and Jacob from Yale.
And I also want to thank everyone
who attended our talk today,
for the wonderful questions they shared,
and the interesting conversations
those questions generated.
So, with that, thank you very much.
And I look forward to sharing
additional ISPS events
in the future with all of you.
Have a nice evening.
- Thank you.